what we're looking at is our previous of
an installation we're doing in a
penthouse suite and Las Vegas it's going
up in a couple months and basically the
task for the job was to create a fully
immersive 360-degree virtual reality
experience so what we're doing is we've
got about 10 computers set up and eleven
different projectors and we're covering
the entire room and about 14,000 pixels
of all real time generated graphics so
if somebody is talking that certain
elements and the scene will be
responding to the audio that's in the
room then composited into the scenes we
have a bunch of girls that are scantily
clad dancing around to the music that's
happening in the room and right now we
only have one girl up but ultimately
they'll be popping up all over the room
in different places depending on what's
going on with the music there's 10
computers one of them is sort of the
master computer and it does all the
music analysis so we have a microphone
in the room and align in from the you
know the in-room music system and it
does all the analysis just like your you
know Windows Media visualizer or
whatever your itunes visualizer would do
so it breaks it into different frequency
bands and then it transmits all that
information out to this to the display
computers and then each one does what it
needs to do with that information
as part of the development process
because it is ten different computers in
order to make content changes it's much
easier for us to control everything from
an iphone I can turn on our calibration
grids so I can use my phone to move all
the different points this one computer
is controlling three different
projectors so I have to align each
projector independently and get them
overlapping in just the right way so
that when i switch back over to the
master content it doesn't look like
there's any scenes they blend perfectly
it's something we've been talking about
for a long time building a fully
immersive cinema experience for home as
like a single box that you would set
down obviously we'd have a projector in
it with the ability to cast light in all
directions or at least in a
hemispherical cover a hemispherical area
so you can cover your walls and your
ceiling the real problem is getting
filmmakers to create media in this
format it is very very different because
you don't have a rectangle you can't
zoom for instance when you're doing a
full 360 all you can really do is move
the camera around in space so it really
changes the way you think about film and
Composition